when it comes to finding a great
conflict to tell a compelling story you
don't get much more classic than sibling
rivalry Cain and Abel were brothers who
got in a fight and settled their
differences with a rock to the head I
guess that settles it so it's no
surprise that every movie in the Thor
franchise which depicts Norse gods
smashing monsters and each other with
fists hammers and anything else within
arm's reach use the sibling rivalry as a
launching point in all three
installments the first to feature the
conflict and subsequent reconciliation
between brothers Thor and Loki as the
most important features of their plots
meanwhile Thor Ragnarok takes things a
step further by introducing a third
member of Odin's brood hella who takes
over Asgard and motivates her feuding
younger brothers to work together to
defeat her
but as Marvel Cinematic Universe fans
have since discovered plans were
underway behind the scenes to give Thor
and Loki yet another different sibling a
brother who might be more familiar to
comic book readers and lovers of Norse
mythology that's right Balder the brave
was almost introduced to the MCU to
further complicate Thor's family tree
former Marvel Studios head of visual
development Charlie when sent MCU fans
into a frenzy back in August 2018 with a
single Instagram post when posted
concept art for Thor the dark world that
revealed his take on adapting longtime
Thor comics character Balder to the big
screen while the characters inclusion in
the film was eventually scuttled it's
exciting to imagine how the MCU might
have been different had Balder survived
pre-production so what's the big deal
about Balder well for starters he's got
more right to the throne than either
Thor or Loki at least if Marvel Comics
and Norse mythology have anything to say
about it the films depict Frigga played
by Rene Russo as Thor's mother but
outside of the film's its Gaia the earth
goddess who is Thor's real mom while
Frida is actually his stepmother
when explained the character's
importance during our exclusive
interview Odin was sort of doing
something on his side that he shouldn't
have and then he brought Thor baby Thor
back and Frigga and Odin brought Thor up
so in a way it's like Baldur's really
the true heir to the throne if you
really want to put it that way and so
there's a lot of things about that
character that can be really key to this
story
however the filmmakers behind the MCU
know when to stay faithful to the comics
and when to streamline and simplify in
order to keep the average moviegoer
interested it's one of the reasons the
MCU works as well as it does and
introducing Balder to the mix and the
dark world would have made a mess of an
already pretty complicated story one
featuring spacefaring Dark Elves a
reality warping infinity stone and kat
dennings do you even know what these
things do no neither do I
how could Balder compete with all that
it makes a lot of sense not trying to
force him in because he complicates
things quite a bit you know especially
if you're trying to make a story really
about Thor and Loki but while when and
the rest of the production team tried to
bring Balder into the fold
ultimately the biggest hurdle was just
that there was no easy way to introduce
the character into the MC use
increasingly complex continuity at least
there weren't any that also gave him the
importance the comic says he should have
in the comics he is the one that's
supposed to be able to he triggers
Ragnarok right he's the one that
actually triggers that whole event of
the destruction of Asgard he's an
important character in the comics how do
you integrate him without him feeling
like he's just an added character right
so I think ultimately not having him in
or one or two I think makes sense when
left Marvel Studios to pursue his own
creative endeavors in 2014 so he's not
involved in the future of the MCU at
least not directly but as it turns out
much of the design work he did at the
company still pops up in Marvel movies
so many years later so despite the fact
that we've yet to see Balder appear in
the MCU to this point doesn't mean Wen's
designs won't make it onto the big
screen sometime in the future check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more exclusive looper videos with
Charlie when about the creation of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]